je ne pense pas que tout le monde
expérimente régulièrement la solitude
existentielle
je suis assez confiant que tout le monde
l'a déjà vécu au moins une fois et je
pense qu'on doit être un certain nombre
à l'éprouver de temps à autre par
solitude existentielle
je veux faire référence un sentiment de
solitude qui serait liée au simple fait
de vivre
je ne parle donc pas d'une solitude qui
dépendrait d'un contexte ce serait
plutôt une sorte de sentiment en veille
en toile de fond comme toujours là et
qui se manifesterait par ci par là quand
on recense là ça semble empreint de
vérité comme si c'était indéniable
comment la décrire je dirais que c'est
le sentiment d'être prisonnier de soi
même au fond on pourrait dire que c'est
le moment où on sent qu'on est
prisonnier de son propre esprit et que
personne jamais ne pourra se mettre à
notre place ne pourra savoir l'effet que
ça fait d'être moins c'est un drôle de
truc quand on y pense surtout qu'on aime
bien l'idée de pouvoir partager des
choses j'ai l'impression d'ailleurs
qu'il ya beaucoup de petites joies qui
sont associés à l'impression d'être
sorti de cette prison on pourrait dire
que lorsque les gens discutent il y as
souvent cet espoir de vérifier tout
autre hui a eu une expérience similaire
à la sienne
on utilise tous les outils linguistiques
à notre disposition pour essayer de
décrire ce que l'on a vécu on confronte
sa à l'écouté d'un ami pour savoir si
cela fait écho à la manière dont lui
décrire et son expérience qui n'a pas
déjà été rassuré d'entendre un récit
d'expériences similaires comme si on
disait après on est d'accord je suis pas
tout seul à avoir vu les choses ainsi
par exemple le film parasites
j'ai pas aimé je n'ai pas détesté 1 je
me suis juste ennuyé rien ne m'a
particulièrement excité dans mon
expérience mais c'était très
déconcertant ont tenu de l'unanimité
avec laquelle le film était célébrée
j'étais un peu démunis parce qu'il y
avait un décalage très nette entre mon
expérience est ce que les gens
racontaient de leur expérience
ce qui m'a rassuré donc c'est entendre
un ami où mon frère vous raconter une
expérience qui ressemblait à la mienne
c'est un petit soulagement
ah ok je suis top en fait je crois que
c'est ça l'enjeu et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs on peut s'engueuler sur le
cinéma c'est parce qu'il ya quelque
chose de particulièrement perturbant
dans le fait de reconnaître que l'autre
a une sensibilité différente
d'abord parce qu'une sensibilité ne peut
pas faire l'objet d'un consensus comme
un problème intellectuel qu on pourrait
essayer de résoudre par le dialogue
si une chose ne répugne et risque d'être
très difficile de me convaincre du
contraire se confronter à des
différences de sensibilité est source
d'angoissé
probablement que nous avons l'impulsion
profond qu'il est dans notre intérêt de
coopérer les uns avec les autres et donc
tout ce qui peut se mettre en travers de
la coopération des problématiques
une autre manière d'expérimenter la
réalité ça peut légitimement prétendre
faire obstacle à l'établissement d'une
coopération
ensuite dans un sens plus fondamental
parce que ça peut faire prendre
conscience que la réalité que je perçois
n'est pas exactement la réalité contre
perçoit et donc je suis effectivement
comme coincé dans ma réalité je ne peux
pas voir ce que vaut autrui ça me
renvoie donc à ma solitude existentielle
ce qui m'arrive
ce que je ressens je serai toujours
quoiqu'il arrive le seul à le ressentir
personne ne pourra jamais ma compagnie